Ang ating pinakamahuhusay na klasikal na supercomputer ay nagiging mas makapangyarihan,
at nagiging mas mahusay na tayo sa computation, kasama na ang pag-simulate ng mga sistema.
Pero ang pag-simulate ng kalikasan ay isang napakahirap na problema sa pangkalahatan.
Ako si Victoria Lipinska at ngayon ay susuriin natin ang isa sa mga algorithm
na maaaring gawing posible ang pag-simulate ng kalikasan sa isang quantum computer.
Magsimula tayo sa isang halimbawa at pag-aralan ang caffeine.
Ito ay isang simpleng molekula.
Para i-represent ang energy configuration ng iisang molekula ng caffeine,
kailangan natin ng humigit-kumulang sampung pangkat ng 48 bits.
Iyon ay sampung may 48 na zero
at halos 10% ng bilang ng mga atomo sa mundo.
At talagang nagiging mas malala pa ito.
Kung mayroon kang 125 orbital at gusto mong i-store ang lahat ng posibleng
configuration, kailangan mo ng mas maraming memorya
sa iyong klasikal na computer kaysa sa bilang ng mga atomo sa uniberso.
Imposible itong i-represent kahit gamit ang mga supercomputer.
May pag-asa naman para sa mga quantum computer,
dahil likas silang mahusay sa pag-simulate ng kalikasan.
Para sa isang molekula ng caffeine, nangangahulugan ito ng pag-represent
ng sistema gamit ang 160 qubit.
Mukhang mas kayang-kaya na iyan.
Iba't ibang quantum algorithm ang naiminungkahi na nagpapahintulot
sa mas maliliit na quantum computer na heuristically i-simulate ang kalikasan.
Ipakilala: ang variational quantum eigensolver o VQE.
Ang VQE ay isang algorithm na tumatakbo nang bahagi sa isang quantum
computer at bahagi sa isang klasikal na computer.
Nagbibigay-daan ito sa atin na mahanap ang mga halaga na nalulutas ng isang optimization problem.
Ang VQE ay malapit na may kaugnayan sa iba pang mga pamamaraan na kinasasangkutan ng
pagbabago ng mga parameter tulad ng quantum approximate optimization algorithm.
Ang pag-identify ng mga aplikasyon ng VQE sa iyong industriya o pananaliksik
ay isang uri ng sining, pero may mga maluwag na gabay.
Sa pangkalahatan, ang VQE ay applicable sa mga problemang maaaring i-cast
bilang isang optimization problem na may continuous na mga variable.
Ito ang kaso, halimbawa, sa malaking bahagi ng quantum chemistry.
Madalas, sa chemistry, interesado tayo sa ground state.
Ang ground state ay ang estado ng pinakamababang energy ng sistema.
Upang mahanap ang ground state energy, ginagalugad ng VQE
ang energy para sa iba't ibang configuration ng sistema
at hinahanap ang configuration na may pinakamababang energy.
Sa mataas na antas, ang VQE ay tumatanggap ng deskripsyon ng quantum system
at hinahanap ang pinakamababang energy.
Ginagawa nito ito sa pamamagitan ng pagbabago ng configuration ng sistema.
Sa simula, kailangan nating mag-input ng angkop na deskripsyon ng sistema
na naiintindihan ng quantum computer at isang hanay ng mga parameter na nagdedeskriba nito
na io-optimize.
Ang quantum na bahagi ng
algorithm ay nagghahanda ng sistema sa isang estado
na inilalarawan ng isang partikular na hanay ng mga parameter at kinakalkula ang energy.
Habang ang klasikal na bahagi ay responsable
sa pag-optimize ng mga parameter na iyon sa bawat hakbang.
Ang quantum-klasikal na prosesong ito ay inuulit
hanggang maabot natin ang pinakamababang energy.
Ngayon ay pag-aralan natin ang nangyayari sa loob nito.
Ang energy configuration ay karaniwang inilalarawan sa Hamiltonian
at karaniwang ito ay isang napakalalaking matrix.
Sa algebra, para mahanap ang pinakamababang eigenvalue ng matrix
na katumbas ng pinakamababang energy ng sistema,
gagawin nating basta ang singular value decomposition.
Gayunpaman, ang mga matrix na titingnan natin ay exponentially malaki
at ito ay isang exponentially mahirap na problema na gawin ito nang algebraically.
Ang Hamiltonian na ito ay kailangang i-represent sa anyo
na naiintindihan ng quantum computer.
Kaya isinalin mula sa wika ng chemistry patungo sa wika ng quantum computing.
Huwag mag-alala sa mga detalye.
Sa huli ay mayroon itong mga naka-program na paraan para isaling ang Hamiltonian na karaniwang
nakikita sa chemistry patungo sa isang Hamiltonian na naiintindihan ng quantum computer.
Pagkatapos ay ini-input natin ito
kasama ang circuit, na tinatawag nating variational form.
Ang pagpili ng variational form ay isang uri ng sining.
Muli,
kinakatawan nito ang ating pinakamahusay na hula kung ano ang quantum state ng sistema.
Ang variational circuit na ito ay parameterized ng isang hanay ng mga parameter na theta,
at nag-i-input din tayo ng paunang pagpili ng mga parameter na ito.
Batay dito, ang quantum na bahagi ng VQE ay:
inihahanda ang reference state, halimbawa, ang zero state;
gumagamit ng parameterized quantum circuit, ang variational form, para maghanda ng quantum
state para sa paunang hula ng mga parameter sa quantum computer; at tinatantya nito
ang energy na katumbas ng estado na sinusuri sa pamamagitan ng Hamiltonian.
Ang tantyang energy na ito ay pinapasa
sa klasikal na optimizer, na naghahanap ng bagong hanay ng mga parameter.
Ang mga parameter ay bumabalik sa quantum solver muli,
at ang buong proseso ay inuulit.
Nakakahanap ang quantum computer ng bagong tantyang energy, ang
klasikal na optimizer ay naghahanap ng bagong hanay ng mga parameter, at iba pa.
Inuulit natin ang prosesong ito hanggang mag-converge ang solusyon.
Ibig sabihin, hanggang ang pagkakaiba ng mga resulta sa pagitan ng mga hakbang ay maliit na
para sa ating pangangailangan.
Sa katapusan, ibinabalik ng algorithm ang na-minimize na energy.
Okay, magaling ito.
Pero baka nagtataka ka kung paano natin malalaman na talagang gumagana ito
at hindi tayo aksidenteng makakahanap ng energy na mas mababa kaysa sa hinahanap natin?
Magandang tanong iyon.
Lumalabas na hindi tayo makakatantya ng energy na mas mababa.
Ito ay dahil sa tinatawag nating variational principle.
Sinasabi ng variational principle na ang pinakamataas na lower
bound sa energy ng sistema ay palaging ang
pinakamababang energy nito na katumbas ng ground state.
Nangangahulugan ito na ang energy na sinusuri sa anumang iba pang estado ng sistemang iyon
ay palaging magiging mas malaki kaysa sa pinakamababang energy.
Samakatuwid, sa VQE hindi tayo makakakuha ng anumang bagay
na mas mababa kaysa sa ground state energy.
Gayunpaman, maaari ngang mag-converge tayo sa isang bagay
na mas malaki kaysa sa minimum na hinahanap natin.
Ito ay madalas na tinatawag na metastable solution
at ito ay isang hamon na sinisikap na lutasin ng mga mananaliksik araw-araw.
Kapaki-pakinabang ang VQE dahil gumagamit ito ng mas mababaw na circuit
kumpara sa iba pang mga protocol na nagpapahintulot sa atin na tantiyahin ang ground state energy.
Ginagawa itong angkop para sa near-term quantum hardware.
Sa video na ito, nakita natin ang isang sulyap ng magagawa ng VQE at kung paano ito nabuo.
Pero hinihikayat kita na suriin ang Qiskit sa kontekstong ito.
Kahit nasa simula pa lang tayo ng ating quantum journey,
maaaring makapaki-pakinabang na ito para sa mga problemang sinisikap mong lutasin.
Ako si Victoria Lipinska at ito ay isang pangkalahatang-ideya
ng variational quantum eigensolver algorithm.